breaking overnight the death toll is
rising in Indonesia where at least 384
people were killed by a strong 7.5
earthquake that then triggered a tsunami
hundreds of people are still unaccounted
for on the island of Sulawesi in the
city of Paulo the tsunamis waves of
almost 18 feet struck a beach Friday
thousands of homes are damaged or
destroyed and roads are cut off and
communications are difficult Jonathan
Vigliotti is in London with the very
latest Jonathan what can you tell us
yeah good morning this devastating
tsunami hit at sunset as you mentioned
with the city of peluda rectly in its
path large crowds were actually gathered
on the beach for a festival when those
waves reported again up to 18 feet high
pummeled the coast sweeping many to
their death cell phone video captured
the terrifying moment one of those waves
washed in swallowing seaside homes you
see it there people could be seen
running in fear for many though
especially those on the ground not fast
enough the massive waves quickly flooded
streets with a force that destroyed
anything in its path the waves were
triggered by a 7.5 earthquake which
alone caused massive destruction
Indonesian television reported an entire
shopping mall was destroyed along with a
bridge and even an 80 room hotel
ultimately though it was the tsunami
those waves that caused the brunt of the
damage witnesses say it took more than
four hours for the water to subside
first responders reported finding bodies
pinned under the rubble of collapsed
buildings and trapped in vehicles that
were swallowed by the waves the death
toll is expected to rise emergency
response has been impossible for some
areas where roads have been destroyed
until the communications knocked out as
those rescue operations continue strong
aftershocks have been reported and
Anthony that's raising concern for more
life-threatening damage Jonathan
Vigliotti thanks very much Jonathan